and now give me great pleasure to
welcome the 17th president of MIT
Rockville rife who will speak to us
first and I introduce our keynote
speaker circling me let me see if it
worked for me
good morning I was also thank you Lulu
for for your nice introduction and many
things to everyone who helped to bring
us together this morning including our
host the Committee on race and diversity
the MLK planning committee and our
Institute community and equity officer
at Virginia and above all a huge thank
you to our student speakers our
incredible student speakers eToro answer
here you make us all so proud thank you
this morning this morning we'll come
together to celebrate in the spirit of
dr. King the value of activism
especially student activism in driving
social change so I begin by
congratulating all the winners of this
year's MLK Leadership Award I recognized
that the staff and faculty who work on
this issues play a profound role in our
community but in the context of today's
event
I offer special recognition to the
student winners Rashid August of the
Black Student Union the black Raja
Student Association George Chow an
activist for graduate student concerns
and fossil-free MIP in terms of student
activism on our campus this has been
quite a year an extraordinary year on
topics from race inclusion and social
justice to climate change our students
have in many ways become our teachers
that has been true on campuses across
the country but our students have done
things differently in a way that I
particularly admire I want to show just
one example an image that we'll never
forget
I chair a group at MIT called Academic
Council it was referred to it earlier
this morning about 30 of MIT stop
academic and administrative leaders we
met we meet Tuesday mornings 1qz in
January for the first time that I can
remember a group of students were
invited and came to our meeting the
leaders of the BSU and the be GSA
presented their ideas for making the MIT
community more diverse and more
welcoming for all many of you know these
students I'm telling you they were
magnificent
they were thoughtful they were creative
persistent specific collaborative
constructive and serious they went out
of their way to incorporate the views of
students from other underrepresented
groups as well and with academic council
they set the tone of mutual respect and
they earned tremendous respect in return
the students brought the recommendations
to address issues specific to MIT today
improving orientation and adding booster
shots of inclusion education after
freshman year enhancing financial aid
collecting and publishing new types of
data about the student experience hiring
more diverse mental health staff
providing training to overcome
unconscious bias and the list goes on
today these students are collaborating
with academic councils brand new working
group on inclusion together they are
addressing these recommendations and the
problems they aim to solve the working
group will share a public progress
report in time for spring break and I'm
confident I'm confident that we are on a
path to sustained and meaningful change
you may find interesting to know that
Academic Council has volunteered to be
the pilot group for unconscious bias
training for this exceptional example of
student activism of initiative and
constructive leadership I'd like to
publicly say here to them thank you in
Bravo
as one of our student leaders pulled it
recently it is wonderful to see the
gears of MIT go to work on a problem and
I could not agree more one last
observation when this student spoke to
Academic Council they made it clear that
some of what needs to happen has to do
with human values they are asking us to
say out loud that we value the diversity
of our community I do they are urging
all of us adamantly to maintain a human
perspective and to remind each other
that while the quality of our students
work is important their mental and
physical health is most important I
agree and finally they're making a
powerful case there are more welcoming
more inclusive MIT would be better for
absolutely everyone they are right and I
look forward to working with them to
make this vision real and now I'm
honored to introduce this morning's
keynote speaker Freeman hrabowski is
president of the University of Maryland
Baltimore County he has held that job
for 24 years now I've been president
here for three and a half years I must
tell you
Freeman's record will be tough if not
impossible to beat but I take comfort I
take comfort in the knowledge that he
had a tremendous head start over me he
was born eight days before me
as many of you know through his
leadership of UMBC Freeman has
accomplished something deeply important
at MIT some of the work we admire most
comes at the intersection of theory and
practice when a powerful idea translates
into effective solutions in the real
world president hrabowski has become the
leading theorist and the most
accomplished practitioner of the science
of empowering students of color and
women to succeed at the highest levels
in STEM fields UMBC is a predominantly
white institution by living up to his
vision by living up his vision it has
become a national leader in the number
of its minority graduates who go on to
earn doctorates doctorates in medicine
in the sciences and in engineering
what's more his efforts have become
models for colleges and universities
across the country for example in 1988
Freeman helped launch new embassies
widely recognized meyerhofs
scholar program for young black men
interested in science and engineering
the program provides each scholar with
academic support as well as personal
advising and mentoring year round for
the first two years of college their
success rates are through the roof and a
very high percentage of them gone to
grad school in STEM fields at MIT we
were so impressed that four years ago we
adopted key features of the Meyerhoff
model for a program we call interface
age it serves about 70 MIT undergraduate
say year and the first interface age
cohort will graduate this June and we
have Freeman to thank for the model and
for the inspiration Freeman has also
co-authored three books on how to help
young people succeed and he has won a
great many honors in 2000
9 Time magazine named him one of
America's best college presidents three
years later they declared him one of 100
most influential people in the world and
in 2012 President Obama asked him to
chair the newly created president's
Advisory Commission on educational
excellence for african-americans
Freeman's awards and achievements are
remarkable but I'd like to mention just
one more in 2015 US News and World
Report named UMBC one of the most
innovative national universities MIT
made at least two in fact our two
institutions came in third and fourth
nevermind which one was which but but
number one was a rizona state number two
was staying four so I'm planning to
strike a deal with Freeman for us to
stick together and earn the two top
spots next time
in short in short as our diverse
community seeks a path that combines the
highest level of intellectual
achievement with a warm sense of welcome
and inclusion for all we could not ask
for a better guide and friend than this
morning speaker please welcome president
freeman a brewski
I enjoyed hearing that we're the same
age and that you were number three and
we were number four you you had about a
hundred years ahead of us you were
founded in 1861 so you and you have
quite a bit more and your endowment so I
think pound for pound we're doing okay
also all right William Carlos Williams
once said that it's difficult to find
news in poetry and yet men die miserably
every day because of a lack of what is
found there and so I begin with the
words of our beloved and now late Maya
Angelou who looked into the eyes of this
country and said lift up your eyes upon
this day breaking for you give birth
again to the dream women children men
take it this dream into the palms of
your hands molded into the image of your
most public self sculpted into the shape
of your most private need here on the
pulse of this new day you may have the
grace to look up and out and into your
sisters eyes and into your brother's
face and say simply very simply with
hope good morning good morning to MIT
good morning give her a hand for poetry
give her a hand for poetry
I was so impressed by these students
today I got goose bumps
and your theme is truth and power I
would have called the truth to power as
they both spoke so eloquently about the
challenges we face in our society the
challenges we face on our campus as
whether it's MIT UMBC the fact that we
can be better than we are
and that students have a very important
role to play in helping us look in the
mirror as a nation and the society as
institutions give all the students in
the room a round of applause
I was delighted to talk with Ralphie
yeah as a fellow president as someone
who cares deeply about these issues and
who was asking me really wonderful
questions about my perceptions about my
students who come here I've got several
students here today where if I have an
alum who's here today who's here at MIT
or somewhere Harvard MIT that several of
you here you are you in the room stand
up if you are if you're never room stand
up and give them around applause
wherever they are
very nice
very proud is very proud of them getting
rid of the finished PhDs in the sciences
and MD PhDs between Harvard and MIT and
we've had a number of students that come
here and to do well I dedicate this talk
to two people one is Robert Meyerhoff
who isn't actually a graduate of MIT all
the way back to the 40s and a wonderful
philanthropist who worked with us from
the beginning of our program to think
about how do we help more at the time
african-americans in particular to
succeed in science on a campus for
dominantly white when I'd first gotten
there
we're students of color and particularly
there in that Baltimore area black kids
were not doing well in science and we
started with young black males at a time
when nobody wanted to talk about males
of color you see and it was bob mayhawk
who said i'm already working on some
issues with my wife's alma mater Gaucho
and women and I want to see he said
because everything I see on TV about
black males if it's not support it's
about handcuffs or guns and this was
back in the late 80s give him a round of
applause for having that kind of vision
and now we're proud to say we have
students of all races it's still heavily
african-american and Hispanic but males
and females and we lead the country not
only in producing blacks are go on to
get PhDs and stem among predominate
white schools but for any type of
institution we're number one in
producing blacks who are going to get MD
PhDs give us a big round of applause
and the other person I want to mention
is another graduate of your institution
at the undergrad level
Janice Lumpkin the late Janice Lumpkin
and it's hard for me to talk about it
because she she graduated from here in
chemical engineering and she went to the
University of Pennsylvania became the
second african-american woman to get a
PhD in Chemical Engineering and she came
to our campus and she was amazing and
she helped us to develop at my program
in those years and support it and it was
the first time so many of my students
whether and I have students in 150
countries it was the first time most of
them had ever seen an african-american
woman faculty member in engineering of
any kind you get my point so she began
with that ability to say it is possible
to do it but then she brought to it such
compassion and brilliance and this
ability to pull people together and to
say we are better than this we can do
this and she inspired so many of the
Meyerhoff but so many of my white
students are gone to graduate students
and particularly women she tragically
died in childbirth but she had just
gotten tenure and we celebrate her
legacy and I want you today to think
about the idea that this institution
produced both above my heart a a
wonderful philanthropist people say what
was bought my heart black I said black
his name is maja they said well you know
when your name is hrabowski so a
wonderful Jewish philanthropist who
simply cared about people and other
people's children and then a wonderful
brilliant young woman from Shaker House
Heights Ohio from Cleveland who came
here and had some people who cared about
her had some challenges yes yes but who
went on and got that PhD and knew the
significance of giving back to others
and so I want you to think with me for
the next few minutes about the story of
America about your stories
students faculty staff members alumni
each of us has a story if I were to tell
you and give you a theory in this room
you might be interested most audience
tonight would not be interested in this
room you might be interested and I will
tell you that if you look at my writings
you'll see a theory of social
transformation saying that our
universities for dominantly white
universities I wrote it several years
ago must look in the mirror and rethink
the culture of the institution that is
not just about students changing I saw
this on my own campus I still see it as
we work on these challenges it is about
the entire institution changing thinking
about its values its assumptions the way
it treats people empowering people that
would be the theory I would give you and
we used it in our I chaired I was the PA
of our advanced program when we talked
about more women faculty members with
usually with the mouth scholars with our
Center for women and IT but more
important for the entire institution to
say all of us must be involved in this
work if we are too poor people in who
have not been historically represented
at the institution we must hear their
voices
we must think about who we are and who
we want to become and my essential point
today as I tell you my own story is that
the way we think about ourselves as a
society as the Academy as MIT as UMBC
the language that we use the way we
interact with each other the values that
we hold will shape who we are not only
today but in the future in other words
our dreams and our values really become
who we are and so I'm sitting in the
back of church in the middle of the week
as a 12 year old and I was always a
little nerdy kid loving math I've always
loved me I get goosebumps still doing
math and I'm forced to be there because
my parents say we want you to hear this
guy talk and they bribe me with the two
things I love most eating and
and math so I'm eating M&Ms the good can
with the peanuts and doing my man now
I'm 12 but I'm in then I'm about to go
to the tenth grade I've skipped grades
now because I'm so smart but because I
had wonderful wonderfully educated
parents who had been working with no
worry problems all my life who had
taught me to study Dostoyevsky when I
was in middle school because they knew
the world wouldn't be fair to a little
colored child and that I had to be twice
as good and had to read broadly and
study a lot of my mama who taught math
in English would work with my father and
they work with me to make me ready so
that one day when I had a chance to be
in class with my kids one day I would
not feel inferior and so I'm sitting in
the back of church and I'm I'm getting
fatter and smarter all the time as I'm
good as man you know the southerners
Atlanta we like those cheeks you know
that our heart gotta have no padding
right and and the guy says if the
children participate in this peaceful
protest all of America will understand
that even our babies our children know
the difference between right and wrong
and I look up because I'm thinking about
these hand-me-down books that we have to
use in our schools and our all-black
schools and my parents not allowed to
buy my books because then I'd be
different from other kids so you have to
use these raggedy books that came from
the white schools when they finish using
them after years awful for us to have to
feel that we were so second-class that
we got their hand-me-down books and so I
look up and I say who is that guy and of
course his name was dr. Martin Luther
King and I was absolutely transformed
because his message was this that the
world of tomorrow could be better than
the world of today and that I a child
could be empowered to be a part of that
transformation that it wasn't just about
what he would do or what my parents
would do he wanted me to be involved I'd
go home and I say I've got to go I've
got a marching this peaceful protest and
my parents look at me and say absolutely
not no you cannot and I am so not upset
not academically perturbed I am
all right I am so upset and I look at
them and I said you know you guys made
me go I did not want to go you told me
to listen I actually did listen he tells
me what he wants me to do and now you
tell me I can't do it you are here for
crits at that time students it's alright
that you did not tell your parents they
were here for Chris right go to your
room boy and for that night I knew I was
in trouble but the next morning they
came in it was the first time I'd ever
seen my parents looking you could tell
they had been crying and they said it
wasn't that we did not trust you we know
that if you go you will go to jail and
we don't trust the people in jail who
will be over you but if you are
determined to do this and you've thought
about it and they said why do you want
to go and I started that said how these
hand-me-down books right you know I've
got some good teachers but everybody
says the white schools are better you
know you tell me you want me to get in
we go through this argument we talk
about it and then they finally say we
will put you in God's hands and now if
the situation will reverse and my kid
who's now grown had at 12 I'm not sure I
would have allowed him to go you get my
point
it's scary and I was not a courageous
kid students the only thing I've ever
attacked in my life was a math problem
all right if a fight broke out I was
running the other way all right okay not
even saying to admit it but here's the
point we did go and I did leave my
little group because they were kids as
young as 8 and 9 and 10 and while I was
only 12 I was a high school kid I was I
was more mature and here's the point we
learn in that five days in jail
horrible experiences but we also learned
that even children can be empowered to
know they can make a difference and
there is my message to you students that
yes you do have the right and the
ability to speak truth to power give
yourselves a hand again for speaking
truth
the power
and so what does that mean today what
difference did it make well as
interesting enough if I wrote an article
and it was so amazing to me to realize
that most of the people in this country
today were not born raffia in 1963 watch
this how many of you were not even in
the world in 1963 had not been born that
is disgusting I want you to know I want
to tell you to get out just get out it
turns out I did I did
two-thirds of Americans were born after
1963 so the experience that you hear me
talking about for most of you it's like
something in a book you get my point
and I am that connection with those of
my generation and about who was born at
I mean before that time raise your hands
if you're older than that thank you very
much for being in the room all right I
appreciate that you stay all right you
stay all right but here's my point but
within that period of the 60s when
people spoke truth to power people of
all races spoke truth to power we did
see all kinds of changes for example we
went through the Civil Rights Act and
the Higher Education Act and the Voting
Rights Act all were passed in that
period legislation and what difference
did it make
let me tell you that even here in Boston
in the 60s we could not have had a room
looking like this you could not have had
a woman Chancellor of MIT Cynthia
wherever she is you get my point
for women for people of color it would
not have been the case and the world is
different when I ask Americans the
question what percent of Americans do
you think had a college education when I
went to jail in 1963 what do you think
just spit it out somebody say it what do
you think what percent of Americans had
a college educated completed college
this would be MIT knowing that wouldn't
ya
absolutely right it was only ten percent
four percent of whites I'm hearing 30
and 70 90 I suppose know some math now
have 10% for the whole group the
majority of folks were white right
come on math people in the room right it
was only 11% and for blacks don't be
embarrassed to say it that's what he
told us that say the troop said whatever
it is right sad it was only 2 to 3%
right right and we were not even
counting other groups 10 so general we
have we were talking black and white in
the 60s in fact watch this how many of
you in this room remember something
called black and white TV the older
people and how many students and he have
always had color TV
that's disgusting it really is ever but
today though we go to all the different
groups in our society so what percent
have a college degree today mm-hmm it's
just about 30 percent 31 percent 4
percent of whites it's up to about 37
percent 4 percent of Latinos and
Hispanics the fastest growing in our
country it's just that 15 percent what
was in a blacks it's about 20 percent
represent of Asians it's at 55 percent
but there are certain groups of
asian-americans went that's not the case
it's very important when talking about
diversity to go to specificity there's a
difference between my black students
whose parents are from the islands and
those whose bred care parents are from
South Carolina all those who from
Nigeria there are differences of
Hispanic population my kids who are from
Puerto Rico who are from New York very
different from my kids coming from the
University of Puerto Rico you get my
point they're different challenges
depending on where you're from but the
point is you put it all together and we
can tell you that that literally over
2/3 of Americans over 25 today did not
go to college have not graduated from
college why is that important well all
of my friends white black Hispanic
whatever agent will say Native Americans
numbers below everybody's you know that
we've got to keep working on that issue
but here's the point all of my friends
will say Freeman that couldn't be true
everybody I know went to college duh
do you get it
duh MIT professors no MIT professors
grad students no grad students right
right lawyers no lawyers doctors no
doctors and plumbers who make more money
than any of you all no plumbers all
right the point is that literally we've
gone from 10% to 30% and every group has
gotten better off as a result of that
but here is the challenge the bottom
quarter of our country of the population
of every race the bottom corner of the
students of every race have a
probability of graduating from a
four-year institution that's under 10% I
don't care whether you're white or black
Hispanic or whatever the group right now
until we do more in terms of
intervention to help with both the
academic skills in many cases our little
children in Atlanta or in Baltimore or
here in Boston in terms of the academic
skills on the one hand and then the
issues involving financial aid because
the financial aid issue for poor people
is not that they can't get it from the
federal government it's that nobody's
helping them to fill out the forms
before the deadline if you don't fill
out the forms before the deadline you
don't get the money and if the forms are
as complicated as they are like the IRS
right so it's the financial issues it's
the academic issue but it's also having
the dream the vision and so here's what
I want you to think about on the one
hand as your students were saying it is
so important that we look at our own
institutions in higher education to
understand why students of all
backgrounds black students and others
Hispanics and others are saying around
the country there are challenges on
these campuses we're not necessarily
made to feel like we belong here or
people are making all kinds of
statements and assumptions I'll never
forget when I got an a on the algebraic
topology code test in grad school and
the I'm not little black kid in the
class and the professor writes on my
paper you did surprisingly well now
remember I told you my mother is an
English teacher I go up and I say why
the adverb
he didn't know what I was talking about
I'd like that I like that record and
when I pointed to the word surprisingly
he all he could do was turn red the
advantage black people have is we don't
turn red all right got to put humans in
his stuff tella true but put a little
bit to it he's it a little bit and and
amazingly just recently that person sent
me the message that in his old career as
he retired that I had taught him the
best lesson about looking in the mirror
and the assumptions we make if you've
not seen a little black kid in a
topology class you assume it can't
happen when we said at UMBC that we
wanted students not only to succeed but
to be excelling to be the very best and
when we said we want to be able to place
students on the faculties of the best
institutions in the country that we
wanted to produce not just MDS with MD
PhDs we wanted people to dare to know
and to be at the top people said
impossible impossible I'll never forget
when I went to one big Foundation and
talked about evaluating the program and
I'll never forget them saying Freeman
it's gonna take generations before
blacks will get PhDs and the person
looked at me and said you don't have the
gravitas yet in your race he said that
to me and it was amazing I looked at him
and he said now you're an exception but
you know you don't have the gravitas you
get my point
people always want to make the one
person the exception right yeah I went
through school early yeah I finished my
math major I was 18 because I had had
advantages and dared to know what about
being smart it was about being blessed
to help people who kept working on me
and focusing on me
anybody in here whether you come from
money or not and many of you don't but
you had somebody in your home somebody
in the school who took interest in you
and made the difference you are the most
privileged human beings in the world at
an MIT you of them and when I came here
years ago roughly Elford with my
different mark writing and talked
20-some years ago - all the chairs and
we were talking and it was he was saying
these departments represent the best of
their kind in the world and it's
inspiring
but here is what I want you to think
about as you think about being the most
privileged all of you students faculty
and staff we must learn to look in the
mirror at ourselves for the students I
would say you should say what you're
feeling what you're experiencing at the
same time know that this experience is
preparing you for the next level because
the more advantage you are the more
you'll continue to be the only one
wherever you go
I have always walked in and been the
only one and people have always wondered
is he really qualified after 25 years as
president I still get that sometimes it
is what happens right why am I telling
you that yes we want to tell the truth
but we need to decide who are we as a
student Who am I as a professor as a
president of MIT or UMBC and what
difference can I make
I would say to you as the most
privileged in the world you have the
capacity to solve any problem you're
solving some of the greatest science and
technology problems that exist on my own
campus we are working on stem 1/2 more
than half my students are in stem
students from all over the world and I
see how the intensity of students from
other countries I use that to get my
students from this country that get that
sense of that that intensity if you look
at the Nobel laureates throughout the
20th century so many of them came at the
time in the 20th century from European
countries their parents didn't speak
English well in New York they went to
the poor man's Harvard City College
Brooklyn College why did they do so well
from the humanities listen that in that
hunger that intensity we have a
Chesapeake Bay Retriever on our campus a
dog and we have the statue of him who is
our guru he's our mascot and my
basketball team reads really well I want
to tell you that meaning they don't win
a lot of games but they read where they
will all right and we're great in
debating great in chess you know we do
our really well
lacrosse those better soccer does well
but there we are a nerdy place all right
and we've got a hundred companies on
campus and what we are always talking
about is what makes the difference he's
a company site about my students in both
faculty what makes the difference it is
that we call ourselves the house of grit
the Chesapeake Bay Retriever is named
true grit
and we're making the point to America
stop talking about this kid is smart and
that kid is not smart it's about how
hard you work it's about having support
from people to help you pull you into
the work what makes the difference in
the microprogram
is that faculty on our campus most of
whom are white most of whom are still
white men advances got me up to 39
percent women assistant professors
they'll give us a big half of that they
have that and we've got just getting in
our first people of color in these
departments but the key is that my white
guys guys get it if you look at my new
book I put the publishers want to know
why aren't you putting blacks all blacks
on the cover I said no because in
science power is across races and white
guys are powerful am i right my best
friends right so Mike summers the Howard
Hughes investigator my dear friend has
produced more african-americans who are
going to get PhDs and biochemistry than
anybody in the country and so he is
there with the HIV virus there people
are thinking this art it's HIV because
he studies that you know and what's
amazing is I've got a young black man
there my mom then I got one of my
mentees who's a young Korean am a
korean-american all of them looking at
this disease and thinking this is a
problem of human kind and therein is the
dream that people of all races men and
women come to know each other well
enough trust each other well enough work
hard enough that they work to solve the
problems of humankind
give the dream around of applause the
dream of solving the problem of feeling
and so I want you to listen to
marketplace from yesterday I was so
pleased it just happened to come up that
they've got interviews of my faculty in
the morning and the evening and it's on
confronting biases in faculty hiring and
the significance to the approach we are
using is while there are people of color
helping in the training the real
ambassadors and trainers are all white
whites who are the most highly respected
on my campus who've agreed to come
together to work collaboratively with
faculty to help us to diversify the
faculty give my campus at hand for
having the courage to do that that's on
NPR for marketplace um yesterday and so
I want you to think about the students I
want you to think about the notion yes
you want to think about things on this
campus but you also want to think about
things in this community and back in
your own communities because I cannot
say it enough you are among the most
privileged and you want to deal with the
issues here as much as you can it takes
time for some things to happen but you
want to you know you need to support
when you when you're having a hard way
you need to know and believe that a
sense of self is most important you must
have a biblical build a community around
yourself of people as she said appears
to her appears of people who consider
you it'll be okay and then you want to
identify family and staff who will give
you that support and you want to get
into those office and say I need your
help
never keep it to yourself if you've got
problems tell somebody say I need this
help whether it's in a class or it's
about emotional experiences that you're
having and ask questions in the lab ask
questions in the classroom ask questions
in your dorm wherever you are it was I
Robby the Nobel laureate who said when
he was growing up in New York all of his
friends parents mothers particularly
would say what'd you learn in school
today
he said but not my Jewish mother he said
my Jewish mother would say Izzy did you
ask a good question today and the
practice of encouraging his curiosity
made in the thinker he became and so I
challenge you MIT to ask the good
questions not just about science and
technology
but about humankind about the human
condition what would it take to have
more diverse faculty if students are not
having the right experiences are we
listening to their voices not just
because they're impressive as truth
tellers but because we want to figure
out the strategies with specificity that
can change the environment because
students have been asking questions on
this campus and all of our campuses for
at least 30 40 years it's been a 50-year
experiment that we have been working to
pull more people into this work and my
final point to you involves the notion
of struggle anybody who loves math or
science or reading TS Eliot understands
that the most fascinating work comes
when you have to dive into it you I'm
working I'm reading TS The Waste Land
for 35 years to understand every time I
read it layers of understanding coming
from the experiences I've had so my wife
and I are just celebrated a big
anniversary and we gave ourselves a gift
of going back to learn French and and
social clean my films you mean my music
to do la francais matter no to Liz
you're my professor attorney to do dr.
Wong when we say la owner Richard Eyre
de France the Normandy and new Zevon
passe do Tom a Polly in each porno turn
anniversay Karen st. give me a big hand
45 years of marriage 45 years but I
leave you with one statement in one
quote from a poem it was Apollinaire the
port in one of his forms that says
lesoire Vanitas you're a paler pen
lesoire Vanitas you're a pilot pen the
joy comes after the struggle all of this
is about a struggle anybody who's
working to learn anything substantive is
struggling anybody who's trying to
change a UMBC or MIT is struggling
because it is not hard it is not easy
the Academy does not change easily for
any of us it takes effort
it's a 1954 the schools were
desegregated in the 60s I still couldn't
go to a school that was integrated you
get my point it takes we have to keep
working at it you know in that last year
before Janice Lumpkin died when she died
I
Esther what has helped you to be the
woman of courage you are she was such
powerful presence and she said I
remember how blessed I am to have had
wonderful parents who gave me support I
remember both the professors who
supported me and those who didn't think
I would make it both inspired me she
said and I understood that nothing takes
the place of hard work and attitude and
I am determined to help my students
understand that of those to whom much is
given much is required
mit you must do what we are doing you
are supposed to be placing the students
of all races men and women on the
faculties of cross this country you
supposed to be the place that's saying I
am an MIT graduate I believe you can do
this you have the best brains in the
world of every race here I challenge you
in my tea be the best not just in stem
but for humankind watch your thoughts
they become your words watch your words
they become your actions watch your
actions they become your habits watch
your habits they become your character
watch your character it becomes your
destiny dreams and values thank you all
very much
you